good luck
okay hi everyone so I am in these
pandemic times one of the things I'm
doing which I'm finding a lot of fun is
doing general q and A's for kids and
others but primarily kids about science
and technology so I'll try and answer
whatever questions you might have let's
see I think we already have some here
okay there's a first question here
actually what physical experiments do I
recommend for kids that is an
interesting question hmm
interesting question you know I have to
say my own efforts at those when I was a
kid were pretty lame I'm thinking about
that you know getting intuition about
how things work in physics is something
I think one does from just paying
attention to things going on around one
I mean I think that the question is you
know why did that happen it's more I
think the the art is more and the
question one asks that are necessarily
doing the thing that has an unexpected
result I mean it's like you see
something happen and you say why well
you see some strange technological
object then you say what is that and why
was it built that way I mean that's
that's been my probably my best comment
on that now they're also a computer
experiments there are lots of those that
are fun for kids to do Lots involving
simple programs like cellular automata
one of the things that's neat about
those is it's it's really easy to
discover stuff that basically nobody
ever discovered before because it's sort
of a wide open area that hasn't been
much explored but I don't have a maybe I
if I think about it some more I'll have
a better answer to two actual physical
sort of hands-on experiments people
people can do but I think the most most
important thing is to actually ask why
did things
and see whether you can explain that or
why is a piece of technology built the
way it's built why does you know why
does that um that you know phone have
this thing set up that way and I suppose
that that extends beyond the pure
science of it to things like the user
experience of it why did they make why
is it the case that you know the the
buttons on a phone the the soft buttons
on a phone work the way they do why is
it you know try to understand why these
things happen and that's that's a sort
of very educational thing to do um okay
so question from pH something asking
about the physics project which we just
launched last week and the possible
connection of the project to making
space travel more possible you know
that's far away I mean back in you know
when Isaac Newton was inventing his
universal law of gravity the the the law
that says that the gravitational force
between two things as the inverse square
of the distance between them that's
something that Isaac Newton first came
up with probably in about 1665 when he
was when he was hanging out sort of
locked out of his university by plague
actually um but he came up with this law
of gravitation and in principle that law
of gravitation should have explained
that it's possible to have artificial
satellites to to launch things that can
be in orbit around the earth but it took
until well it took until the 1950s the
late 1950s before which was a full 300
years basically almost 300 years between
the time when the theory for how one
might launch something in orbit around
the earth to the actually launching
something in order around the word earth
happened now in terms of in terms of
this physics theory that we've been
working on so one of the questions is
what does it say about things like
faster than light space travel the
answer is at least in first blush it
seems to say
that's hard there's no there's no sort
of magic way to do that but it also says
that's not completely impossible if one
makes use of quantum mechanics in the
right way and so on not completely
impossible we certainly don't know we
don't know how to do it I mean a lot of
the more exotic effects are ones that
have to do with black holes and you know
the the we don't have any sort of black
holes available in the lab on earth the
nearest black hole actually I don't know
how far away it is maybe a thousand
light years away maybe a little less
than that um there's a big black hole at
the center of our galaxy the sort of
giant garbage can of our galaxy that's
that's ingesting stars and all sorts of
other things we are we are far away from
it we will not be ingested by the giant
black hole center of our galaxy but the
so you know some of the effects that um
this physics theory predicts or talks
about are things that happen in
connection with black holes but those
are not sort of readily at hand
um okay it's a question here from
Lexington you have suggestion of someone
who finds math fascinating wants to
learn more but is not a math whiz and
has difficulty with homework and tests
well I don't know what a math whiz is
necessarily it'd be a sort of a school
level I know I'm not sure that I for
example was a math whiz in the sense
that when it come for example okay this
is one of these stories one shouldn't
tell for the young but I'm gonna tell
him anyway you know I didn't learn my
multiplication tables until I was a full
adult and I I perhaps had the misfortune
of being in a an elementary school I was
supposed to learn multiplication tables
the sort of there were things like they
had some game where all the kids would
line up and they would go down the line
of kids asking randomly chosen
multiplication facts and if people
couldn't answer the multiplication fight
it would go to the next kid next kid
next kid in the first kid who could
answer the multiplication fact would go
to the front of the line so to speak and
I learned that the one fact that people
didn't know was what
seven times eight so that was the one
thing when I was seven years old or
something that I definitively learned
seven times eight is fifty-six but that
was the only one all the other ones
because they were randomly chosen
multiplication facts most of the other
ones like five times three in these
that's easy I can work that out
but you know six times nine things like
that I have tried to keep track of when
that I need to know that and some of
those facts I think I learnt finally in
my 40s or even older than that
eventually I did learn them I know that
um one of my kids who was not into doing
any kind of math at all but was very
interested in in business I was like oh
you know he was like why should I learn
to do any mental math and it's like well
let's say you're trying to do some kind
of business negotiation in real time and
somebody says I'll give you ten percent
more for this it's like it's good to be
able to actually work out what that
means and I think that convinced him and
he got to be actually pretty good at
doing those kinds of things um but you
know in terms of I think there's a
difference there's different kinds of
reasons that people are good at or like
math some people like kind of the the
abstract elegance of math some people
like the kind of the problem-solving I
can get it faster than anybody else side
of it some people like the you know what
you can do and figure out with math I'm
kind of suspecting from your question
that you're more in the kind of the
elegant abstraction of being able to
work out something really really nice
and perfect with math I would say that
you know you know become friends with
computers and start doing math with a
computer and start seeing what you can
discover about math with a computer I
think I tried to do a couple of sessions
ago here and there's a certainly a
recording of it I tried to do some go
through some sort of pretty kind of from
the school perspective sort of
elementary math questions and was sort
of remarkable how quickly we could go
sort of with a computer particularly
from the questions that you might be
reasonably expected to answer in sort of
elementary school math to questions
where well
people have been thinking about them for
2,000 years but nobody knows the answer
yet um so I think being able to sort of
explore math experimentally with a
computer go to our cloud you can start
plot start playing with things there
that's a that's a good place to start
you know I actually myself have had a
project started about three years ago to
try and write a kind of introduction to
the abstract ideas of math sort of for
everybody
but I haven't I haven't gone out and I
got about four or five chapters in and
maybe I should post what I have I'd be
interested in feedback from people who
are who might find that interesting um
all right next it's a question here from
Hameed how far are we from building von
Neumann machines I'm not quite sure what
you mean by that but kind of guessing
what you mean is self-replicating
computers or self-replicating systems so
so one of the questions is you know when
we see biology one of the one of the
sort of notable features of biology as
biological organisms manage to make
copies of themselves
well at least approximate copies you
know given given to parents you can make
a child and the child isn't the same as
their parents as as as many people as
many children are will point out to
their parents I certainly did to my
parents my children have pointed out to
me the children out the same as parents
but they are they're made from the same
kind of they're they're similar so to
speak and in some organisms there's
there's sort of directly direct
replication of of a parent to to child
organisms so one of the features of
biology is this this amazing capability
to make a copy of an organism and you
know it wasn't known back in in the
1950s in 1940s and early 1950s it wasn't
known how that could possibly be how did
what was the what was the mechanism by
which an organism could make a copy of
itself and doesn't got john von neumann
tried to come up with sort of a an
elaborate kind of theory for how life
might work and how things might make
copies of themselves and he came up with
a very elaborate theory most of which
isn't really so relevant although he did
sort of
invent the idea that maybe it was like a
program maybe it was like a computer
program and then in 1953 the DNA the
structure of DNA was was was decoded and
it was realized that the DNA molecules
that essentially all life on Earth
except for RNA some some things only
have a sort of half of DNA RNA like the
virus we're all fighting right now is an
RNA virus but um but basically DNA is a
molecule that stores the programs for
all organisms like for example our DNA
for humans is six billion base pairs
long so it's about um let's see that
means it's about three it's about three
gigabytes of data going at the right
place no it'll be half that 1.5
gigabytes of data to represent one of
our one of us humans and and what
happens when sort of when a human is
built so to speak what's happening is
inside each of our cells there are
there's a whole molecular mechanism
that's looking at that program on our
DNA and actually building molecules that
implement that that are specified by
that program and and some of those some
of the pieces of that program will
specify you know skin cells hair cells
heart cells muscle muscle cells those
are just different parts of the program
that is specified on every cell all the
hundred trillion cells and our bodies
have a copy of that piece of DNA so it's
kind of it's this scheme for being able
to replicate it the way it works is DNA
is a molecule which has two strands and
in order to replicate what happens is
one strand comes off and then basically
another strand is formed from the from
the scaffold and that's created that
because these strands each each strand
has it has some toad that's made from
these little little collections of atoms
base pairs ATG and C and they're set up
so that whenever there's a G on one
strand there has to be a C on the
corresponding strand so if you only have
one strand and you start trying to
rebuild another strand if there was
Gyan the first stand you'll get to see
on the second strand and eventually you
have essentially a copy of the copies of
these essentially a just a essentially a
copy of one strand on the other strand
and that's that's how you managed to
replicate the molecule so so we've got
in all of us in all life on earth
there's this idea of self-replicating
molecules we have not yet managed to
make with technology anything that works
as a self-replicating molecule and the
way that DNA works we're getting closer
to that but we haven't managed to do it
yet um and and when people think about
doing technology that involves
self-replication they usually actually
think about leveraging without using
what biology is already constructed
using DNA and RNA and all those kinds of
things so one question is so one thing
is can you make a self-replicating thing
that isn't based on biology and isn't
based on something that has come out of
the history of life on earth over the
last two billion years and so on and the
answer is we're not quite there yet
although it's clear we could do that
with a molecular it's kind of a
molecular scale computer but we don't
yet know quite how to do it actually let
me say something about molecular scale
computers so I mean computers as they
exist right now you know computers store
information bit by bit so they're
they're storing you know any any data
and a computer is ultimately stored in
terms of ones and zeros on or off etc
and there's just a huge array of those
and so you know I think my computer has
96 gigabytes of of random access memory
which means it has about a hundred
billion times eight so see this is where
multiplication facts come in useful so
that's eight hundred billion nearly a
trillion bits of memory each is just
specifying sort of on or off and and
ultimately that's representing all of
the programs and images and everything
that I'm that are in my computer but the
but the way the each one of those bits
in my computer is represented by the
presence or absence of maybe 10,000
electrons
so that's like you know in inside atoms
their electrons and electricity is made
up of electrons and each bit in a modern
computer is represented by maybe 10,000
electrons so if there's a one there's
10,000 electrons there if there's a zero
they're not there okay so we can ask the
question could we make a computer in
which bits of information are
represented one electron at a time where
we only use one electron we only use one
atom to represent each bit of
information in our computer well the one
problem with that which is that there
tends to be when you get down to those
small scales there's there's always the
kind of well as for example always heat
there's always some things are the
molecules the atoms are not completely
stationary they're always they're always
sort of bouncing around and as a result
of that there'll be it's like that one
electron that was supposed to be there
well actually maybe something will kind
of just knock into it and the electron
won't be there when it was supposed to
be there or there will be an electron
there when there wasn't supposed to be
there but with little errors that creep
in when you're using just a really tiny
number of electrons to storage bit well
actually there's a trick for food but so
so right now so that's one of the
problems is that when we get down to
trying to store you know one electron
per bit will be subject to all of these
errors that come about through just the
the things that happen down at the scale
of atoms the sort of random motion and
random processes that happen down at the
scale of atoms okay let me mention one
trick for um it's called error
correcting codes and it's a way of it's
a way of being able to be sure about
data that you have so let me give you an
example the so let's say that you wanted
to store you wanted to store a sequence
of ones and zeros and you had let's say
you were storing five ones and zeros and
so you might have one zero zero one one
that might be what you're trying to
store one zero zero
one okay but now let's say we want to
check whether one of those bits was
wrong let's say the first one might be
flipped to be a zero and we're not sure
and we say that there might be an error
of that kind well here's the trick so
what you do is you you just say you look
at the one zero one one what did I say
what ones did I say five bits yeah yeah
one zero one one so then then what you
say is do you have an even number of
ones or an odd number of ones if you
have an odd number of ones add an extra
one at the end if you have an even
number of ones put a zero at the end so
we have one zero zero one one and that
has an odd number of ones so that we
have one at the end okay so now if we're
looking at that group of six bits six
digits and we see that we can then ask
the question did that bit at the end
agree with that did it correctly
represent whether there were an even an
odd number of ones if it did correctly
represent it we can have some confidence
that there wasn't what we know that
there couldn't have been one of those
one of those bits that was flipped
because if it had been flipped then that
last check digit should be different
okay so so that term so and if it if it
if it's wrong if that last bit doesn't
correctly confirm the number of ones and
the in the previous part then then we
know that then we know that something
went wrong and so we can for example say
well we have to reread it or we have to
generate some error or something like
that so that's a that's sort of the
basic idea of an error correcting code
actually one can do a little bit better
than that and one can by adding a little
bit of extra data but you have a bunch
of data you add a little bit of extra
data you can actually correct errors you
can for example if you say there's only
one error there's at most one error you
can say well I know what that from just
the check digits at the end you can say
I know what that error is and I can
correct it if there were two errors you
might be out of luck but if there's only
one error you you can correct it so
error correcting codes are really really
widely used and
sure as the data from my webcam through
the internet to you guys is being
transmitted it's full of error
correcting codes that are trying to deal
with things that might be bits that
might be being lost in different places
um and the if you look at um I don't
know what if you look at a book do I
have a book readily at hand mm-hmm no I
don't think I can no reach reach and
find it but let's see if I can reach and
find the book here we go okay here's a
book it's out is through a book I wrote
but um that's some so if we look back
here if we look there that is the ISBN
number the international standard book
number that's every every book that's
published gets one of those numbers that
specifies it so it's a way of
identifying which book it is well when
is PN's were invented one of the things
that was done was to add a check digit
at the end so if somebody were to were
to type in this ISBN number and they
would get one of those numbers wrong
then that nine at the end that's the
check digit that nine at the end
wouldn't agree correctly and so they'd
know they typed in something wrong um so
that's an example of one of these error
correcting codes so that's a way that
one can go if one's trying to build like
a computer out of out of atoms that's
one of the important tricks one can use
to try and get rid of the effects of
kind of sort of small small
perturbations small errors that happen
at level of atoms one of the things
that's been a kind of a long-running
question is okay how would we build
something that where we have like let's
say we wanted to build a little machine
a little a little thing with gears or
something and we want to make it
actually out of atoms and we want to
make it so that the gear teeth so that
each gear tooth is just a small number
of atoms is that a possible thing we can
do well actually if you want to know
about like rotors like something like a
gear turns out there are bacteria that
actually have little flagella that are
used to little propellers that they use
to swim along that actually have
essentially molecular sized gearing in
them where the where the individual
the individual pieces of the kind of the
gear are at the scale of a fairly small
number of atoms that's something that
was created using the machinery of life
but the question is can we make so that
was something that was created from
their DNA program the molecules were
created that followed that DNA program
that made this kind of gear structure so
the question is can we can we do
something like that
not through DNA not by using biological
evolution to have created the apparatus
to do it but could we make as a piece of
technology something that will make a
molecular scale machine so the answer is
not yet but one day that will be
possible and you know somebody is going
to figure out how to do this see the
thing that is right right now when we
want to build things out of molecules
the main way we do that there are really
two ways to do it one is to use living
systems and to use the fact that DNA can
encode a program that can specify how
certain kinds of molecules proteins can
be built up
that's way number one way number two is
use chemistry because a lot of chemistry
is about synthesizing molecules going
from one set of molecules and saying you
know mix these two chemicals together
heat them up stir them stir them
together all those kinds of things and
what's happening when you do that is
molecules are combining breaking apart
all those kinds of things and what you
want to do in chemistry chemistry is
kind of the story a synthetic chemistry
at least is the story of how do you go
from let's say perhaps quite small
molecules to bigger molecules that do
something useful
so like molecules that can be used to
make materials ones interested in
molecules that can be made to use to
make drugs one once those kinds of
things and that that story of kind of
how do you how do you synthesize
molecules is is a story of how do you
find this procedure and these days you
know there may be a 20 step procedure
maybe the biggest ones are maybe 30
steps or something maybe 35 steps let's
say do this do that mix these chemicals
together do this do this do this and
you're gradually building up this bigger
and bigger molecule it's kind of the
the story of can you can you figure out
how to sort of make changes to the
molecule you're building up so that you
get the molecule we want that's kind of
been the story of chemistry but that
doesn't really make molecular scale
machines that usually makes molecules
that just sort of sit there and for
example there are a particular shape and
so they'll fit in to some some gap in
some other molecule to prevent the
molecule from doing something you don't
want it to do or there'll be molecules
that line themselves up in a certain way
but those molecules aren't like machines
they're not they're not like actually
sort of doing something at a molecular
scale they're not making something with
a bunch of cogs and gears and things at
a molecular scale and we don't know how
to do that yet um I think I personally
think that's one of these kinds of
things which somebody some clever
inventor out there is going to figure
out how to start building things at a
molecular scale I think it's going to be
something where you effectively you
build yourself molecules that can act as
tools and then you build yourself ways
to sort of program those little tools
and the tools will be operating at the
scale of individual molecules and
there'll be sort of constructing other
molecules and gradually you'll start off
with pretty simple tools but gradually
you'll end up building up more and more
complicated molecules and eventually
you'll be able to build these sort of
molecular scale machines okay so this
was a sort of long answer to so I think
that's one of the really exciting things
that I think is part of the future of
technology is molecular scale molecular
scale machines molecular scale computers
those kinds of things not there yet that
but perhaps we will be and one of the
features of those molecular scale
machines is well we can expect that
we'll be able to do things like what
life does of being able to take a
blueprint for this as a collection of
molecules we want to build okay now I've
got a universal replicator a machine
that can be given a program okay let me
back up for a second you know DNA as I
mentioned lets us build certain kinds of
molecules lets us build proteins
proteins are made of amino acids there
are maybe 20 amino acids that are
commonly used by by the organisms on
earth and a protein
a sequence of amino acids so it might be
and the what that sequence is is
specified by the program on the DNA by
the sequence of base pairs on the DNA
and the the neat thing about proteins as
proteins make up everything they make up
you know muscle active active as a is
something in muscles or they make up
rhodopsin for you know in our retinas or
they make up oh gosh I could start
naming you know there's there's about in
us humans there's about thirty thousand
proteins I think that uh that are
commonly that that sort of a commonly
used by us us humans
hemoglobin for our blood or all these
different kinds of things these are all
proteins and they all are built from
these same elements these same twenty
amino acids and different orders and the
one of the neat things that proteins do
is depending on the order of those amino
acids the proteins some amino acids tend
to attract each other sometime to repel
each other the proteins will fold
themselves up into really complicated
patterns and the shape of the final
protein is critical to how it works like
for example you know actin is a this
long filament or a protein that's used
for muscles completely different from
hemoglobin for example which is a
protein that has a sort of a little cage
in the middle of it that that likes to
have iron atoms in that cage and that it
kind of it floats around that sort of
collects iron atoms because only an iron
atom fits in that particular shape and
structure of cage in the protein and
those iron atoms are used to kentukcy
gene in our blood so proteins just by
having the these different tongue
sequences of amino acids they end up
being different shapes and they end up
having different functions and they end
up interacting differently with other
proteins and that's kind of the story of
how how we get how we actually operate
as living systems is we're full of
proteins that do things now a question
that you can ask is let's say proteins
are very specific kinds of molecules
made from amino acids but let's say we
wanted to make more orbit
kinds of kinds of things out of atoms so
for example one one pretty versatile
kind of thing is carbon so carbon is an
element and you know one thing carbon
makes is the graphite that you find in
pencils and things
another thing carbon makes his diamund
those are really different I mean
graphite is black looking thing that's
quite soft diamund is this transparent
thing that looks that's really hard and
those are both made for just
arrangements of carbon atoms in in
graphite the carbon atoms are arranged
in kind of sheets each one will
hexagonal a sheet of hexagonal
arrangement of atoms in diamund there's
a particular way of in which the atoms
of carbon are packed together that makes
them more closely packed and have the
very have the strength of diamond has
but both of those materials are just
made from carbon atoms and not so long
ago about 30 30 to 40 years ago another
form of carbon was found called bucky
balls which are kind of like like like a
soccer ball and they every sort of the
joins on a soccer ball imagine you put
carbon atoms at every join our soccer
ball that's an example of a Bucky ball
made from its it's kind of this cluster
of carbon atoms and that's something
where there are all kinds of weird
applications in nonstick frying pans and
all sorts of other places for Bucky
balls and there and there are other
forms of carbon things called carbon
nanotubes that might be really useful to
make really good wires for conducting
electricity and things like that but all
of these things are just carbon atoms
just arranged in different in different
ways and so one of the questions is if
you just say I want to make you know
some weird shape out of carbon atoms how
do I do that right now nobody knows how
to do it you know when bucky balls were
discovered they were discovered almost
by accident in insert actually where
we're just you know carbon have been
sort of arranged randomly and some of
the things happen to arranged in those
kind of clusters but it is almost
certainly the case that there is a tet
well I'm sure it's the case they
is a way of constructing it at an atomic
scale sort of an almost arbitrary shape
out of carbon and so you know you can
imagine that as sort of a future for
technology is these these atomic scale
things that have been constructed even
just out of carbon but if we say well
let's allow other materials into the
into the picture we can say well how
will we construct an arbitrary object
how will we just make a thing that from
a program can just sort of knit together
this thing made out of atoms that
contains you know silicon aluminum I
don't know copper carbon whatever and
just sort of knit it together an
arbitrary shape we don't know how to do
that yet one day we will um and and one
day we'll be able to make it so that all
these different kinds of objects that
we're constructing are well we specify
how to make them but not only that
instead of them just being there as sort
of materials that just sit there and and
do nothing
there'll be things which can actively
respond to their environment I mean so
for example you know plastic big
invention of the nineteen only 1900s
I mean plastic is these molecules that
are these long polymer molecules where
there's it's mostly carbon hydrogen
oxygen um where am
you've just arranged them in in mostly
carbon and hydrogen actually where
you've just arranged a long sequence of
atoms that all fit together
to make these very very very long
molecules but the wrong molecules don't
really do anything they just make a
material that has certain properties one
can imagine a time when one could make
something where there's actually a
little computer operating sort of at the
level of individual molecules so your
material instead of just being a
material that sits there and has
mechanical properties that has a certain
strength and things like that is a
material that can do all kinds of things
it could respond to you know could
respond to its environments and it could
start changing color like a chameleon or
something or it could do all kinds of
all kinds of strange things where it's
where it's operating like a computer but
at the scale of atoms so that's one of
the one of the things in the next part
I know 50 years or something I think you
can you can readily expect that that
will be possible I mean I think it's the
the there was a time when all the
materials we had were natural materials
we had things like wood we had things
like copper we had things where you
could go into the natural world and you
could just mine that material or go
collect it by by you know chopping down
a tree or something um in what happened
in the late 1800s Early 1900s
was the first kind of synthetically
created materials which plastics with a
big example and today you know we're
very used to synthetically made
materials materials that have been made
you know artificially but we're not yet
used to materials that actually compute
at the level of individual atoms and I
think in in in the future it will seem
like oh you know really there were
materials that were just static
materials that didn't have computation
built into the material that will be
surprising to people okay
looping back to the original question
about von Neumann machines so kind of
the thing that came out of von neumann's
really fairly incorrect actually ideas
about sort of how life might work was
the idea that you could make a machine
that would make a copy of itself and you
could imagine something as Roman did
that was at the level of you know giant
pieces of you know gears and things you
could see and the machine would have you
know arms that would reach in and do
this in that and the other on the we can
also imagine as I was sort of talking
about at some length there machines at
the level of molecules and atoms and so
on that could make copies of themselves
but the the question really is could we
imagine something where a machine makes
a copy of itself and and the answer is
absolutely now you know what could we do
with that well actually we are in the
middle of an ugly situation where a
thing is making a copy of itself right
the the the coronavirus is it isn't
quite able to on its own make a copy of
itself like a bacterium is able to on
its own make a copy of itself a virus
cannot a virus needs to kind of hijack
our cells to make copies of itself and
so for example
I think let's see we probably have this
point about so how many copies of the
coronavirus the coronavirus is basically
a bunch of RNA it's pretty small piece
of RNA it's about 29,000 base pairs all
curled up inside a coat
that is that sort of keeps the DNA it
keeps the RNA sort of stable inside
because RNA unlike DNA is quite an
unstable molecule and it has some some
extra little spikes on the outside but
that that little tiny thing it's it's
what it's maybe a hundred nanometers are
a hundred billions of a meter across
that little tiny thing um when when it
uses our cellular apparatus can can make
copies of itself and I think last I
worked out let's see I haven't worked
this out in a while I think it has maybe
maybe there are a hundred billion
trillion copies of that virus that have
now been made in the world um so it's
kind of a hundred right about our a
billion trillion copies of it versus our
temple and humans and so on and you know
we're in the process of winning so to
speak but that's a case where there's
been a copy of that term of that object
that virus that's been made so you know
what people started talking about in the
1950s when when von Neumann machines
were the rage was maybe we can make
spacecraft that will be self-replicating
spacecraft and so one of the ideas was
let's go put something on the moon that
is a factory that can basically make
copies of let's say the factory
well let's send something into space
it's a spacecraft that's out you know
out in the universe and it's going to
make copies of itself well it's kind of
tough because you have to have material
to make a copy from and if you're in
interstellar space for example you might
have one atom every every cubic meter so
that's hardly a lot of stuff to make
copies from but let's say that you you
arrive on your your favorite planet your
favorite exoplanet and you successfully
land there and you
say I'm gonna make copies of myself here
well we're certainly not there yet but
we can certainly imagine a time when
it's possible I don't know whether it'll
be more like you know making copies of
virus or more like making copies of a
little sort of molecular scale object or
more like copies of making a big
spacecraft I think it's gonna be
actually easier to make copies of things
that are little tiny molecular scale
things now you know is it exciting to
populate the galaxy with all viruses not
so clear it might be more exciting to do
it with machines that we feel a little
bit closer to I'm not sure but but
that's some that's kind of so that's a
that's a long answer that interesting
question um there's a question here how
can you connect to the internet if your
mom turns off the Wi-Fi that is a
challenging ah gosh well I mean you have
a cell phone that's um I'll tell you how
I first started using so the the
predecessor of the Internet was a thing
called the ARPANET and I started using
that in 1976 when I was 16 years old um
and it was kind of a funky thing because
in those days every computer there
weren't very many computers on this
network and every computer had a number
and I think there were 512 computers on
the network and you could just you could
go type into a terminal kind of like a a
computer that doesn't compute anything
that's just so you connect to the
ARPANET and I'll explain how you connect
it in a minute and then you would simply
type at oh and then the number of the
computer he wanted to connect to so my
favorite computer was 236 which was a
computer at MIT I lived in England in
those days so it had two that was a
network that went through a satellite
connection and all kinds of elaborate
things but but back in those days you
would connect to these computers around
the ARPANET and there were just 512
and that was and they were all specified
by numbers okay back in those days how
did you connect to the ARPANET well you
actually connected through phone lines
and those were that was when there were
only landline phones cellular phones
didn't exist yet and the the way it
worked is you have a phone line and you
have a phone with a physical you know
receiver that you like hold up to your
ear and things and there were these
things called acoustic couplers which
were these things with kind of rubber
kind of cups and you literally you put
the the phone receiver into an acoustic
coupler and if you listened and then you
dial the number and I'll explain what
happen when you dial the number you
dialed this number to connect to the
ARPANET and when when the when the
number picked up this thing called a
modem modem still exists today although
they're deeply built into the the
technology stack we have a modem would
pick up and it would start making all
these weird whistling noises and pretty
soon it would be starting it would go to
I can't imitate it I I don't think I
could ever have imitated it but I it
some would make all kinds of weird
noises and those sounds were converted
by the acoustic coupler into computer
data and so it was it was basically
sending all its data just through the
sound of what was on the on the phone
I don't know whether you can you can you
might be able to buy from eBay an
acoustic coupler and you might be able
to that that would be a very exotic of
course you have to have a old landline
phone hmm this is a this is getting to
be an archeological technology stack but
what what happened when you would dial
into the ARPANET there was this it's
called tips terminal interface
processors and there were a limited
number of those that um I just had phone
numbers and you would dial up one of
these things and it would it would
answer with it's funny whistles and
things wasn't for a human to call into
it it was for a computer and it would
start then communicating back in those
days the most common speed to
communicate
300 board which means 300 bits per
second so that means so that's let's see
you know I was talking about arithmetic
and now divided by eight so that's about
40 bytes per second so that's 40
characters per second so that means if
you were using the web through a 300
board connection you'd be getting about
40 characters per second being being
typed out so a typical line might be 80
characters long so that means a line of
text would take about two seconds to
come out really slow um actually it was
interesting because back in those days
people used to say um it'll never be
possible to send data they used to say
faster than 1200 board over to 1200 bits
per second over telephone lines I said
just the telephone lines aren't set up
to do better than that well then people
succeeded in making it go faster they
then 9600 board was the next the next
real threshold ah I'll tell you one
funny thing I mean I remember once
ordering some phone connection from the
phone company
which was a higher speed connection or
something and the person came out was
kind of rural place that I was in in
those days and the you know the phone
connection when it comes to a house in
the days before modern fiber optics and
things when it came to your house
there's a big bundle of wires and they
usually but I think 96 pairs of wires
and any given telephone would just
connect to one of those pairs and so the
question of how do you get a higher
speed pair well the person came out and
he just tested these different pairs and
out of the 96 pairs
he found a few that could run data at a
higher speed so who knows what had
happens at the other ones you know some
they were you know there was a little
nick in the wire or something but it was
kind of a funny process that to find a
faster connection it was just like out
of the 96 wires a few of them will be
able to go faster but anyway so then
people used to say oh 9600 baud that's
the fastest you'll ever be able to
transmit data over the copper wires that
were the backbone of the phone network
turns out that was that was that was
that was beaten and in fact nowadays
people people send data routinely at two
million bits per second over essentially
those kinds of connections how did that
happen well the answer is it happened
using error correcting codes the things
I was mentioning earlier and happened by
being able to essentially predict what
kinds of ways the data would be messed
up by being transmitted down these wires
so effectively what's happening is the
the thing that is sending the data is
sending various check information along
with the data and it is whenever
something goes wrong it will resend the
data for example but it knows that
certain kinds of errors will be typical
to occur on those wires and it knows
kind of how to optimally how best to to
package up the data and resend it to
avoid those kinds of errors I mean this
is happening in 5g telephony there's a
yet another round of this let me expire
we're talking technology here for a
minute so let's just people might be
curious cell phones people curious how
does ok so somebody's asking what's my
take on 5g technology alright oh let's
talk about this okay so first of all how
does a cell phone work ok what so cell
phone is using radio and what's
happening is when you're talking on the
cell phone or data or you're looking at
the browsing the web on a on a cell
phone or something it's sending data by
radio to a cell phone tower well you see
these cell phone towers in different
places sometimes they're disguised as
trees sometimes they're on the sides of
buildings and things you'll typically
see them they'll typically have these
kind of rectangular things which are
their antennas sometimes they're just
vertical that's cylindrical vertical
things sometimes they're a sort of
flatter rectangular things those are the
antennas and whenever you're using a
cell phone what it's doing is its
sending radio signals back and forth to
the to a cell tower so one of the big
tricks of cellular telephony is which
cell tower are you talking to because
there are so fat towers dotted all over
the place and the question is your cell
phone wants to be talking to the one
that is that it's typically nearest to
and for example if you're driving down a
highway or something your cell phone
will be the the cell tower that your
nearest to will change as you drive down
the highway and so the it's some it's
there's a question of how does the cell
phone know that it should now connect to
a different cell tower and then when you
have many cell phones connecting to one
cell tower how do they not all get mixed
up okay so first of all the question of
how does it know which cell tower to
connect to roughly what's happening is
your cell phone it used to be the case
in early cell phones you could actually
see the list of cell towers that it was
trying to connect to but roughly what
happens is at any moment it's it's
sending it well not quite at any moment
every so often it will send a little
ping to cellphone towers and it will try
and figure out what is the strength of
the signal from different cell phone
towers and that tells it roughly how
close it is how much how easily it's
going to be to communicate to with a
particular cell phone tower so as you
drive down the highway
it'll handoff from one cell phone tower
to another so it'll be for a while
you'll be talking to this cell phone
tower your phone will be talking to this
cell phone tower then then it'll get
closer to another cell phone tower it
will see that the strength of the signal
from the new cell phone tower is larger
than the strength of the signal from the
old cell phone tower and so it'll do a
handoff to the new cell phone tower it's
a little tricky because you can get into
a situation where you keep on you know
the signal gets stronger weaker stronger
weaker and then you'd be handing you
know you'd be saying okay I'm handing it
off the cell phone tower too and then
it'll be back to one back to two back to
one and that's very inefficient and
causes all kinds of problems so you have
to do some some sort of clever
engineering to prevent that happening so
the other question is how does it know
your cell phone is so so you know when
you teen a radio
people still do you'll hear you know
there's some radio station that'll
advertise itself as you know win ninety
nine point seven megahertz where w
whatever it is at ninety nine point
seven megahertz so what's happening
there is you're the the radio waves that
are generated by that radio station are
they are mostly sort of operating at
that frequency and the the the the the
the data the voice whatever it is
associated with that radio station it's
kind of just a little wiggle on top of
this wave that's coming into your radio
that's coming in at a certain frequency
and so your radio is tuned to that
frequency and then you can detect the
little wiggle that is the actual data
the song whatever else that's coming
from that from that radio station so
each radio station has a certain
frequency and the each radio station is
allocated that frequency and it's told
you have to operate on that particular
frequency and nothing but that frequency
okay when you have cellphones you might
have hundreds of cellphones that are all
trying to talk to the same cell phone
tower and in order for them to have
their signals not get mixed up each one
has to be allocated a certain frequency
or at least that was the original way it
was done that was the way it was done in
1g and 2g um telephony um so the idea
was I think back in those days and it
may still be true there used to be six
hundred and sixty six channels per cell
phone tower per cell generated by a cell
phone tower so a cell will be the region
that sort of serviced by particular
antennas on a cell phone tower and then
what happens is there will be let's say
600 different frequencies that that cell
phone tower can use to communicate with
with the with them with different cell
phones and so it has to happen is when
my cell phone says I'm going to connect
to this particular cell phone tower the
cell phone tower has to tell it or back
in those days it had to tell it you are
allocated channel number 253 out of 600
and that will be the frequency that
channel that frequency will be the one
that you use to communicate with this
cell phone tower if
you handed off to another cellphone
tower you'll get allocated another
channel for that other cellphone tower
and that'll be the one you'll use for
that and so there used to be this kind
of transaction where there be sort of
this this this thing where they where
the sort of this cell phone would sort
of hail the cell phone tower and the
cell phone tower would respond and say
okay you're allocated this frequency go
communicate with me on this frequency
that was what happened in so-called 1g
and 2g first generation and second
generation telephony then um when 3G
came in there was a new idea
that's called well okay actually I'm
skipping I'm sorry I'm actually cheating
here there's there was another idea in
between okay so there was a thing let's
see there was a thing called TDMA time
division multiplexing um boy you're
using my technology memory here
okay so first idea was allocate a
different frequency for every cell phone
second idea is a weirder idea is every
second each second is broken into let's
say a hundred different or a thousand
different different term different
different slices so the first thousandth
of the second the second thousandth of
the second the third thousandth of the
second and so on each one of those a
different little time division and the
idea was that a cell phone will be
allocated not just a frequency but also
a time division or actually it might
operate on a single frequency but a
different time division and it would be
saying the cell phone will be told you
are operating at the thirty seventh
thousandth of every second so in other
words the cell phone your cell phone is
allowed to communicate at the thirty
seven thousandth of a second and not at
any other time okay so how could that
possibly work because after all you're
having a conversation with somebody and
you know you're hearing their voice
continuously but maybe your cell phone
is only sending its data in this little
bin of time there's a little tiny piece
of time well the way it works says that
your your voice
is compressed so that your voice
corresponds to you know you you look at
the waveform from your voice the the you
know the pressure wave from the sound
that coat the microphone turns that into
an electrical signal and then it's
wiggling up and down and you know for my
voice right now oh I don't know it'll
probably be it would be maybe 200 times
as you know most of the most of the
speaking that I'm doing is maybe around
200 times a second it'll be it'll be
kind of going up and down in an
intensity as recorded by the microphone
but then what you can do is to take that
waveform that that signal you get from
the voice and you can actually you can
essentially take all the data associated
with that signal and compress it and
send it as a piece of data much more
quickly so that you're not spending the
actual time it took to say the word
hello or something you're compressing
that and sending the data associated
with hello but in a much shorter period
of time so that was another scheme for
having many cellphones talk to one cell
phone tower so another scheme called
CDMA code division multiplexing was a
cleverer mathematical scheme in which
basically what you do is every cell
phone is allocated a certain pattern of
bits that says when you have an you're
kind of kind of taking this pattern of
bits and you're superimposing it on the
actual the actual signal that the person
is generating and the way it's arranged
is these different patterns are bits
um they oh gosh how to explain the these
patterns of bits are such that if you
try and use kind of the the sort of
cookie cutter of one pattern of bits you
will get the signal associated with that
pattern of bits and you use a different
cookie cutter you'll get the signal
associated with another pattern of bits
and you can just put all these patterns
of bits on top of each other and the
ones that aren't meant for you will just
seem like white noise will just seem
like a background sort of a background
of nothing um and only the one that's
intended for you will be the one you
pick out so that's CD
and that's that was sort of the 3g that
was the one of the big ideas of 3g cell
phones okay um sorry this is a very um
the is a very long long story but okay
what is special about 5g so then we got
to 4G and that's so what's special about
5g is it's got a different idea gosh
okay I can explain this technology okay
so so one question is in order for you
to be communicating with a cellphone
tower how do you have to be able to see
the cell phone tower in other words if
you have a radio signal is it like a
light signal like the the only you know
light will basically just go in a
straight line from one place to another
so you know let's say and and radio
waves if they are sufficiently high
frequency work that way as well they
only go they just go in a straight line
from from the source to the receiver so
essentially it's like it'll only work
for your cellphone will only work if you
can actually see physically you know you
look out out of the car window or
something
can you see a cell phone tower if yes
then your cell phone will work if no it
won't pick up a signal oh I might
mention by the way a little piece of
cell phone trivia um one of the things
if you you know there is a switch off
your cell phones on on planes at least
commercial planes and the and you know
there are arguments people are not quite
sure whether it really makes a
difference to the navigation of planes
but but anyway it seems like a safe
thing to do but particularly if you use
private planes and things that isn't
usually a thing but one thing that
happens in a plane it's kind of a
cruelty to cell phone situation because
the cell phone is expecting to hand off
from from from cell tower to cell tower
like if you were going at 50 miles an
hour in a highway so there's a certain
speed of handoff and so on but if you're
on a plane going at 500 miles an hour
the handoff is very different and in
fact the cell phone will like increase
its power as it tries to
communicate the cellphone signals are
not directed upwards because nobody
expects to be using cellphones from from
the sky so to speak but plus also the
poor cellphone will be desperately
trying to hand off signals between cell
towers and everything will get very
confused I mean when you you know when
you have a internet on a plane the way
that works is well some of that is
ground-based and some of it is satellite
based there's this thing usually in the
tail of the plane that's a pretty big
antenna maybe that big I don't know
something something that big perhaps and
the antenna often if it's if it's a
satellite antenna it will actually move
too as the plane you know moves the the
antenna will be locked in placed with
gyroscopes and things to try and keep it
so that it's actually pointing correctly
at the satellite um ok anyway but back
to 5g so ok so first first thing about
um about cell phones is does it have to
be line-of-sight does it have to be the
case that you that your cell phone can
directly and be in a straight line
seeing the the cell phone tower there no
trees in the way there's nothing else in
the way okay so it turns out on the
frequencies that cell phones usually
operate around 2 gigahertz things like
that they don't have to be perfectly
line-of-sight and there are the there
are things where the the signal well you
get you get all these effects where the
signal is being as being diffracted by
things and so on and it's being it's
being turned in various ways and you get
um the signal can have them can have
different it has a so called multipath
effect where instead of going straight
from point to point there are multiple
paths between you and the cell phone
tower that a radio signal can travel on
so one of the mysteries of cell phones
is you can be standing in exactly one
place and your cell phone signal can go
up and down and that has to do typically
with with changes in something to do
with the multipath transmission and
those changes can be things like
humidity in the air can be changing
somewhere or some tree can be moving or
some very detailed thing can change the
way that that um that those signals work
and can lead to the thing fading out or
fading in and so on
there's also another effect oh yeah
there's all kinds of interesting physics
effects actually from cellphones of the
nulls from standing waves or all kinds
of funny things but anyway 5g okay so 5g
operates at a higher frequency typically
and it is intended to be more of a
line-of-sight thing but the idea is to
have a larger number of kind of micro
cells rather than a smaller number of
big cells and the and so the sort of the
5g idea is just put these sort of little
micro cells for cell phones all over the
place and even have it be the case that
one cell phone can be using another cell
phone to relay its signal so right now
you're always going straight from your
cell phone to a cell phone tower but in
5g you can have these multiple steps and
even potentially be using other other
cell phones to relay things it's kind of
like the way the internet works the
internet often you're using sort of
other computers other people's computers
to relay information through the
internet but um so the way 5g works in a
little bit more detail it's kind of a
complicated thing so so one of the
things that 5g really tries to do is to
have it be the case so so normally when
you have a radio transmitter
it sends radio signals in all directions
in the simplest simplest kind of radio
transmitter is a dipole antenna where
the electrons are just being bouncing up
and down inside a wire and that has a
certain pattern of radio signals that
come out of it that is not quite the
same in all directions but it's not too
different in different directions and
then people make all kinds of elaborate
antennas you know you'll see antennas
with a one main sort of spine and lots
of little pieces sticking out of them
you'll find on talents with all kinds of
shapes and sizes sometimes you'll find
antennas for a while there was a big
thing in cellphones actually to have
fractal antennas that will have these
nested patterns and so on
lots of complicated patterns of
antennas and all those different
patterns have different ways of of
sending radio energy in different
directions and so for example when you
see a parabolic dish that's intended to
be something which which specifically
sends its signal just in one direction
okay so so one of the things is if
you're sending a signal in all
directions you know let's say you just
you have a cell phone tower and you have
a cell phone and the cell phone tower is
trying to communicate with the cell
phone the cell phone tower is sending
its its cell phone its radio signals in
all directions
most of those directions won't be
relevant to communicate it into your
cell phone so what if it could just send
it signals specifically to your cell
phone and not send signals in all
directions if it could do that it would
need to send a lot less energy to your
cell phone it would need to use a lot
less energy because it's not wasting all
that cell phone signal going all that
signal going in other directions so okay
so there's a is this explainable maybe
um so the question is if you have so
let's say you have an antenna like a
parabolic dish you see these dish
antennas in different places you can
steer that dish like if you have a
satellite term a dish that is getting
satellite TV it will be pointed in a
very particular direction it will be
looking at a geostationary satellite
okay there's another tricky thing so
most satellites just go around the earth
and a low-earth orbit satellite goes
around every 90 minutes but satellites
there are about 24,000 miles out from
the from the earth and orbiting over the
equator they their speed of orbiting
exactly matches the speed of rotation of
the earth and so that means that those
satellites sit over one spot on the
earth so that means if you're getting
your television or your radio from that
satellite you just have to have an
antenna that points in this one
direction so if you go and look at your
satellite TV dish if you have one you
will find it is pointing up to a point
somewhat above the equator just just
outside about 24,000 miles up it'll be
pointing sort of if you're in the US for
example will be pointing down so to the
south - towards the equator and up to
look at the satellite and that dish
able to be in a fixed it's just getting
signals from that one satellite in that
one direction okay so and if you wanted
to get signals from another satellite
you would have to you know use a motor
turn the satellite dish um so the
question is is there a way to get
signals from like a different satellite
from a different direction without
turning any dishes and turns out there
is a way to do that and it's a thing
called a phased array and it's kind of a
clever technique that is used a little
bit of math maybe if I pulled up a
notebook here I could I could show you
but um let me see if I can explain it in
a simple way hmm well not so simple it's
just suffice it to say that by by
detecting well it's easier when you
think about sending radio waves usually
when you send radio waves you'll make
this sort of circle you have a
particular place like if you have if you
have something of water making water
waves you just you have a surface of
water you're going you're sort of going
poke poke poke at the center of the pond
and you'll make this set of ripples that
just go out in a circle okay okay so
let's imagine you're doing that in two
places you're making poke poke poke in
one place in making a bunch of ripples
going out poke poke poke in another
place you're making another set of
ripples going out those ripples and the
middle with interval interfere with each
other
and you'll see this pattern of
interference and actually if you have
two circular collections of ripples
they'll actually see two lines where
those were those some circles interfere
with each other if I'm right I think so
yeah um well by deciding exactly what
order the the you what the timing is for
poking poking poking to start those
ripples you can determine what the angle
that those lines where the where the
ripples will line up to make those those
lines of interference and that as more
or less a phased array works except that
the instead of poking water you've got
some electrical signals producing radio
waves and so on and that allows you to
basically steer a radio signal by
without moving anything just by changing
the electrical signals you can
this radio this beam of radio energy to
go in a particular direction and that's
more us how phased arrays work so so
then the idea is for for 5g is that
you're trying to essentially steer
signals so that you're using so that
you're making communication from like
the the the the base station the thing
that's like the cell phone tower and
your cell phone and you're only having
the signal go in that particular in that
particular direction so you don't need
to have nearly as much signal but in
order to find out how you make the
signal go in the right direction you
have to kind of know everything about
the room so for example the signal might
bounce off the walls of the room and it
might it might go through a window in
some weird way and somehow you have to
discover the the the system has to
discover sort of how to best set the
radio waves up so that they will
communicate correctly and so I think
what happens in the in the current 5g
setup these things I think they're
called pilot waves I think that's right
there are that it basically it's sort of
a two-phase thing you're first of all
you're sending out a bunch of radio
signals and they're trying to figure out
what is the environment like around you
okay I know what the environment is like
now I can figure out how to set up this
thing that will direct the radio energy
in a very particular way so that's kind
of that's roughly the the idea of 5g and
it's more about point-to-point
communication rather than you know self
you know one little one little radio and
you know transmitter to another little
one and then going you know before you
get all the way to to sort of the
central backbone of the of the network I
can talk about I mean I maybe I should
talk a little bit about how the internet
works and things but but Tim let's see
I've probably I've been yakking on about
this for a while let me go back and look
at Tim so I was trying to answer the
question I think I was trying to answer
the question what do you how do you
connect to the internet if your mom
turns off the Wi-Fi and somehow I got
into talking about 5g here but but um I
think um I see if you can buy the stuff
to make an acoustic coupler that would
be an interesting exercise um okay
ah talking about deep learning here I
think that's a little sophisticated let
me maybe come back to that um want to
know but the correspondence between
intelligence and comprehension for
example dogs can't recognize themselves
in the mirror but chimps can in humans
people used to study cranial
circumference as an indication of
intelligence the question is can
intelligence be quantified and how does
that all work you know here's the thing
the you know people have these
intelligence tests IQ tests and they you
know they are seeing basically the main
thing you learn from an IQ test is how
well you do on IQ tests and it's just
like if you have if you're you know
running in a race or you're you know
trying to run 100 meters in a certain
period of time the main thing you learn
by how fast you run 100 meters is how
fast you run 100 meters how much you can
generalize you know maybe you can say if
you can run 100 meters quickly then that
must mean you're fit or that must mean
you have long legs so that must mean
you're who knows what and similarly from
you know from any particular thing that
you test there's a certain amount of
generalization you can do you can say
well if you can do that IQ test then you
can do something that is very very
similar to an IQ test and so on and so
there's there's always the question of
you know if you want to figure out you
know who will be able to you know I I
for a living I run a company and we have
a lot of very talented people and I'm
always trying to figure out you know we
have some particular project we have
some particular problem who's gonna be
able to solve this problem the best and
you know so usually the good guide to
that as well if somebody solved a
similar problem before and they've done
a good job then they'll be able to solve
this new problem as well and you know if
you had sort of the the ratings for
who'd solved every problem in the best
possible way then maybe you could use
that as a more sort of scientific way to
guess
who'd solve a particular problem in a
particular way and it's it's a
it's something where I don't think you
know is there people okay so back in the
1930s particularly there was this whole
question is there a notion of a general
intelligence so in other words people
were was it was used for for example
recruiting for the military and other
other kinds of places where ones just
dealing with a large number of people
and it's like okay can you sort of sort
out who should do what and what's the
most efficient way to sort out who
should do what and so there was this
idea that one would you know test the IQ
the intelligence quotient and the
quotient was you know the average would
be a hundred and some people who were
more intelligent would get higher
intelligence quotients more than a
hundred and and other people who weren't
as intelligent would get lower
intelligence quotients and so there was
this idea was there a notion of general
intelligence I think it was called G
oftenly
the general intelligence quotient that
would be sort of a an overall scaling of
who's able to be more intelligent than
who I think what's become clear I mean
as a practical matter for me as somebody
who watches people do you know achieve
things and so on I think the notion that
there's sort of a a a general a single
number that characterizes this is
complete nonsense
and but I think there's a good way to
think about it actually which is OK and
it has to do with actually thinking
about computers and it's something we
should understand from computers so one
feature of computers is in the end it
doesn't so much matter what computer
hardware you have what matters is how
you can program that hardware so you
know I'm running right now on a Mac
computer you know but I might have a PC
somewhere or I might have you know a
cell phone that has a different a
different CPU or different it's a
different computer and it has different
hardware but nevertheless when it comes
to running programs I can run the same
programs on these different computers
it's just a question of how those
programs are encoded for those different
computers and so if you think about that
for brains and for people you know we
all have different brains you know our
the
the in fact you know one knows ones
fingerprints are somewhat unique the the
shape and structure of brains is much
more variable than fingerprints you know
the ways that there are folds and so on
inside brains are very variable so we
all have different brains um and in
terms of our hardware but nevertheless
the the the sort of the programming the
software that can exist on top of that
hardware can achieve the same things
even though the hardware may be
different even though you know one brain
may have this feature that you know they
may have a you know this particular
piece of the brain may be larger than
some other piece of the brain and so on
turns out it's likely with the case that
just like for computers it just doesn't
matter because you know with with
appropriate programming you just do the
same things so then you know one of the
questions is so you know people then
start thinking about sort of a you know
how can you parameterize different sort
of people's different performance on
different kinds of things and sort of
multiple intelligences of parameters of
you know how good are you were telling
what other people think how good are you
at solving analytical problems how good
are you I don't know whether they have
this how good are you like creating new
ideas I don't know um anyway so I think
that there's some there's this whole
question about um so I'm I just I wanted
to you know this all feeds into the
whole question of like standardized
testing and you know you go through
school and you do all these tests and
you know how does that'll work and you
know the main reason that you know there
are it doesn't make any sense for you to
be doing a class but you're not going to
understand other thing in the class so
there's some sense of sort of testing
are you do you know that stuff and or do
you know enough stuff that you'll be
able to do well in this class but then
there's the kind of you know does the
testing really mean something
fundamental about you know you and the
answer is not really
I mean I think you know when it comes to
things like I don't know the SAT or
something for colleges it's like what
does that actually mean you know what is
the what is correlated with
the you know performance in something
like an SAT and I think the only thing
that can be said and I think people have
tried to measure and people create those
tests have tried to measure is you know
how well correlated is it with your
success in the first year of college
well that's what they're trying to get
is something which is well correlated
with your success whatever that means in
the first year of college and I'm not
sure and but you know it is it is
absolutely not something generalized
beyond that I mean it's worth saying
that you know I've had the good fortune
to both know and in many cases in some
cases mentor people who've ended up
being you know very very successful in
the world or doing very interesting
things being able to and it's it's
really a strange thing that there's just
a great diversity in the in the actual
skills that people have and you know you
can get to a really good point with a
very diverse range of different kinds of
skills that one of the things is always
to figure out well what point are you
trying to get to you know what is the
thing that is a match with your kind of
skills and interests and also happens to
be a thing that one can do in the world
today I mean it's it's you know this is
one of these challenges of of do you
want to do something that the world
today either as has a job to do or even
better actually values like for example
I've been you know involved recently and
trying to find the fundamental theory of
physics does the world value that well
people seem to be pretty interested you
know could I make a living doing that
I'm not sure I'm not sure whether
anybody would you know if it's if it's
like will you pay me to find a
fundamental theory of physics I'm not
completely sure that the world is set up
so that that's possible I mean
fortunately I make my living in some
other way and so I can have that as a
hobby and have fun doing it and it turns
out people seem to find it interesting
and seem to value it and that's great
but it's it's you know it's a it's a
slightly tricky thing so um let's see
the
um well though I wanted to talk about
animal intelligence in a minute but
let's some there's a point from Diana
here so how intelligent when it comes
down to how well one can understand and
use one's intelligence you know I have
to say okay I'm gonna give a little
speech right here
um about applying things one learns I
mean one of the things that just drives
me crazy is you'll talk to people and
I'll say you say do you know about this
say well yes I did this course about
this okay so here's a question that's
come up in real life that one's trying
to answer that can make use of the
things one learns in that course can the
person actually you know take the thing
they learnt in that class and apply them
to solve the problem the answer is so
much of the time the answer is no and it
just drives me crazy because somebody
spent all that time doing this class and
yet they didn't learn something they
didn't take away from it something they
can then apply and you know I've noticed
this with with kids for example you know
they'll do math classes and they'll
learn all kinds of things and then when
it comes to okay let's apply what you
learnt about you know the volume of a
sphere is both 4/3 PI R cubed let's
apply that to work out I don't know the
density of the earth given that we know
certain other information and the
concept that you could actually take the
formula for the volume of a sphere which
has been learnt as a matter of you know
learning math and apply it to something
like the earth it's like that doesn't
connect or like for example if we were
talking about some you know let's say I
told you that the the the the intensity
of a signal from a cell phone tower
falls off like 1 over R squared 1 over
the distance squared you know can you
apply that to figure out you know given
certain level of noise can you apply
that to figure out how far away the cell
phone can be these are things which
actually the math isn't difficult and
it's something that somebody kind of
learnt in you know middle school to high
school level math but can they actually
apply it in a real situation there's
often this this terrible sort of fear of
you know can I really apply the thing
learnt or is there something that was
just a thing I learnt in school as
opposed to something that I can actually
apply in the real world and I think it's
a great exercise for people you know as
you kind of experience things in the
world like can I understand that can I
use something I learned in school to
understand that can I make this
connection between things I learnt in
school and things that really happen in
the world and I think this ability to
like take stuff you know and actually
apply it to things you want to solve
that's a that's a really important skill
and I don't think that skill it's not an
intelligence skill in any definition of
intelligence it's really more just a yes
it's possible you can do that it isn't
the case that there's this box of stuff
you learn in school and then there's all
the other stuff and the box of stuff you
learn in school is only used in school
so to speak and I think that say I'm you
know I'm I'm um I'm a big big believer
in the sort of taking things you've
learnt and just applying them in in the
things you run into in life and I you
know I suppose insofar as I've been able
to do a certain amount of Science and
Technology a large part of my okay I
probably have two maybe three sort of
tricks sort of up my sleeve okay one of
them which might be a built in thing is
I have a pretty good memory and so like
the stuff I learnt you know in school
fifty years ago I still think I remember
like I could probably conjugate Latin
and Greek of regular verbs and I
probably would still remember how they
went even though I haven't thought about
that in probably close to 50 years so
you know I and whether whether I have a
decent memory just because I was lucky
in getting a decent memory whether I
have a decent memory because I've used
my memory a lot and so I you know
remember how to remember better I don't
really know but so that's one thing um
another thing is just this you know
apply knowledge from different places
learn a bunch of stuff and be able to
apply knowledge from one place to other
places that's that's something you know
just having the sort of confidence that
that will work is really an important
thing
and I suppose the third third thing is
it's kind of like they choose what to do
I mean there's one thing which is being
able to do what you do and the other
thing is choosing what what you decide
to do like you know when you have that
project to pick what project do you pick
do you project you pick a project you
know how do you decide that this is a
project you should do that this is a
project that's interesting that you're
going to be able to do that you have a
path to be able to do how do you how do
you pick that and you know in my own
case okay so that one of the sort of
weird tricks of my life I suppose is is
the following thing and this is not
necessarily not necessarily kid
applicable although it might be which is
there are these things that I'm
interested in like let's say physics and
there are these problems in these areas
and there are problems that are kind of
like the core problem of that area like
the thing that is kind of the big the
big kahuna problem of that area the
thing that that sort of people have been
saying that's the thing we really want
to solve and they might have been saying
it for 50 years or a hundred years or
whatever that's the that's the core
problem of this field okay so my trick
is just try and solve the core problem
don't most people who are working one of
those fields will say oh my gosh the
core problem it's much too difficult to
ever possibly solve so let's work on
these things that are on the outer edges
that are much easier and you know we'll
make a little bit of progress on the
outer edge and maybe they're a long long
time we'll be able to drill into the
center but kind of my strategy tends to
be just head for the center of
difficulty just try and do the thing
that is the central problem and so what
happens when you try and do that well
sometimes so one thing that happens is
you will be asking questions where the
answers if you can answer that question
even if it's not quite the central
problem but it's something that's sort
of a a one of the bricks that builds up
the central problem you buy by being
able to answer anything right around
there you are achieving much more than
by answering something out on the
periphery also another thing is there
as many people looking at the central
problem because people gave up usually
people said it's too difficult we're not
gonna look at this sometimes and the big
surprise of this physics project
recently is it turns out that the
central problem may not be as difficult
as you thought it was and as everybody
else thought it was and then that's
tremendously satisfying because you find
out has happened with this physics
project it's like I thought these
problems which I've known about for 50
years would be much harder and they just
or not and you know that's that's really
wonderful when that happens although you
can't count on that happening but what
what you can't count on is that if you
make any progress on that central
problem it'll be important relative to
progress that's being made on these more
peripheral things and so you know I
think to me when I when I think about
different fields are different questions
it's always like what's the main
question what's the core question you
know if you're if you're doing a science
project you know science fair project
whatever else you know it's like what is
the core question in this area you're
trying to deal with you know you're
trying to work out I don't know what
some oh I don't know how long does some
kind of I'm picking one where it's
pretty obvious what to do but you know
how long does some kind of germ lost on
some surface or something that's a bad
example because it's pretty obvious what
to do but um some other case where where
it's less obvious and where there's kind
of the where the sort of a choice
between the core problem and a
peripheral problem it's like try and
solve the core problem and maybe you
won't be able to do exactly the core
problem it'll be a little bit to the
side of the core problem but by just
thinking about the core problem you're
already way ahead and you know I think
that the thing to remember is you know
when you look at people who have been
very successful in in well particularly
in more intellectual fields I think it's
particularly true but it's true in a lot
of fields the the question of knowing
kind of sort of what to try to do
understanding what the goal is is often
vastly more important than the
mechanical ability to solve it I mean
like for example and this in this
project to find fundamental theory of
physics um you know some of what's come
up there I you know I'm not
I'm not total totally terrible at math
kinds of things and so on but I will
tell you that the that the math that's
come up in in trying to figure out
fundamental theory of physics is above
my level of math capability now some of
it is above the level of math capability
of anybody right now but there are there
is some of the math that is definitely
you know above what I can easily do in
math um but nevertheless you know I'm
deciding I'm sort of bashing through
trying to get to the answer and I can do
that math well enough to be able to get
through the answer it won't be as
elegant as somebody who was is more
still that doing that kind of math might
be able to do but but because I know
what where I'm trying to get to I'm you
know I and I sort of know enough to be
able to bash through it even though I
didn't do it in the most beautiful
possible way um and I think that's a you
know it's it's important to realize the
the goal is often more important than
more difficult to you know more people
that the set of people who sort of
picking the right goals is is a much is
a is an ability in much shorter supply
than mechanically being able to solve
things to get to those goals and I don't
you know I don't think it needs to be in
shorter supply it's just a question of
of learning to make decisions about
picking out goals and figuring out you
know I think think one of the things
that term like in my particular line of
work of designing computational
languages and things like this
a lot of what's involved and running
companies and so on a lot of what's
involved is just making decisions about
things um and I think you know it's a
sometimes in school it's not really a
making decision about things kind of
kind of thing that you learn and that's
a it's a it's a really you know being
able to just sort of make decisions not
freak out about the fact oh my gosh I
don't know how to make this decision
just uni make the decision maybe you'll
be wrong some fraction of the time
hopefully it won't be disastrous you
keep on doing the next thing anyway I
think come yeah more to say about that
I'm happy to talk more about that okay
let's see um
the yeah so there's a comment here from
Slayer darf saying that one of the
underlying issues is that kids are
taught to pass exams rather than
necessarily to to learn things yeah I
mean I I can't emphasize enough the the
value of like learning stuff you're
interested in that you're going to
remember you know passing the exams well
there are structural things than the
education system where it's like you can
get to the next rung of some ladder
better by passing this exam and so on I
you know it's a really unfortunate that
some aspects of the education system is
set up that way and it's a-you know
sometimes I think with people who are
like trying really really hard to go to
the right college alright whatever it's
like you know be careful what you wish
for because it may be that the selection
process is actually selecting for the
kinds of people for whom that will make
sense and you're not one of them like if
you're a really creative thinker who is
really good at figuring stuff out or
you're really a great entrepreneur who's
good at sort of you know doing business
and so on then going to you know then
then going to the most sort of elite
school or whatever that has the most
intellectual stuff going on it may not
be relevant um and or has the most kind
of sort of perform perform perform kind
of attitude if you're into that kind of
thing different story but there's a
sometimes people are like I really
really really want to go to this place
it's all about performance but actually
the thing that person is best at and
values most isn't that kind of
performance and so you know it's it's
just the wrong wrong match I mean I
think you know the thing to say okay
this is again an off-topic thing but
I'll say it anyway because it's some you
know the thing people don't understand
like about colleges for example people
say oh there's this you know US News and
World Report ranking of the top hundred
colleges whatever it is or its some this
is like assuming that that colleges are
completely plug compatible that is that
you know they're a college like a really
college it's just not true you know they
have different personalities and
different kinds of students who go there
different different kinds of you know
styles of operation and so on and
I think people you know it's sort of the
this concept of let me go to the better
one because it's higher up on that
ranking um is is kind of not you know
it's the better one for you so to speak
which may not be the better one
according to the slightly dubious
statistical analysis that's done to make
these kind of you know one-shot rankings
and it's kind of like it's almost like
the intelligence story it's like you
know reducing the college to one number
is kind of unfortunate for the college
because it's kind of like um you know
there's this whole college with hundreds
of years of history and all these
different professors and all these
different facilities and so on and now
you're going to reduce it to this one
number of what its ranking is and that's
kind of not not the right way to think
about it I think um let's see um the
yeah I mean you know another thing that
happens okay I'm getting on too many
soap boxes here but another thing that
happens is you know when you're in many
lines of work not all in many lines of
work in careers what matters is to do
things absolutely as well as possible
it's not that there are lines of work
where it's more important to just in the
in a fixed amount of time get as far as
you can but there are plenty of lines of
work where the real goal is you know do
it as well as you can doesn't matter
whether it's some you know and and sort
of partial credit isn't really a thing
it's like if you're writing a piece of
software and it's like well I get
partial credit the things full of bugs
and it crashes for everybody you know
twenty five percent of the time but I
should get 75% partial credit that isn't
really doesn't make any sense and I
think one of the things that can happen
in you know in school is that people
will end up doing things where they're
running very fast they're doing all
these classes and they're getting sort
of partial credit from everything and
that's a bad model for for a lot of
kinds of professions and so on where but
it's not what it's about it's about you
know can I really do a good job can I do
that project and really make it great um
rather than you know can I do it fast
enough that you know I get sort of
almost there and I kind of get partial
credit for it right you know I think the
thing that
well you know different people learn in
different ways but but I always find a
lot of for example we have a summer camp
for high school students which we'll be
doing online this year um and you know
it's a very project-based camp where
kind of the idea is do an original
project and I think that sort of the
process of well first of all the process
of do something that nobody's ever done
before and the process of do it as well
as you can admittedly we have time
constraints there which is unfortunate
um but you know these are these are
really worthwhile things to and and I
wouldn't say specifically about a camp
but I mean in general just do projects
you like I mean like I kind of a funny
thing for me I I did a lot of physics
projects when I was a early teenager and
you know you can find the results of my
projects on the web now it's kind of I'm
kind of I was actually quite proud of
myself I was reading stuff I wrote when
I was like 12 13 years old recently in
the context of this fundamental physics
project it's quite decent actually um
it's it's some but you know I I did that
just because I was interested in it I
didn't do that in any way for school I
didn't do that I don't think anybody in
any school I was I'd ever even saw it um
and you know it's something in fact
anything was seen by anybody until I put
it on the web a few years ago um but
it's something that I found really
interesting and I was probably kind of
educational for me and it was something
that you know I took sort of pride in
doing as well as I could okay somebody
asks the question do I know Brian Greene
yes I I know him I I enjoy him um
okay question is from AAS my kids are
currently reading your book a new kind
of science is your new physics book
within reach of kids
um high school yes below that probably
no I would say pieces of there are parts
of the book that talk about kind of how
these simple models work the intrinsic
character of these models that should be
accessible the parts that are sort of
some parts are more kind of dealing with
the existing sort of corpus of knowledge
in physics and those I'm afraid are
probably a bit advanced I would suggest
if you look at the announcement blog
post that I wrote that's kind of a a a
good introduction to the project that I
I think should be accessible and you
know accessible maybe with a little bit
of looking on the web to to learn what
some terms mean and so on um okay
there's a question from an IDI here
asking about um can I explain how
particles acquire mass I can talk about
what mass is but I don't think for here
because it's a little bit complicated um
I think one of the things that's really
exciting about this physics project is
we actually sort of know I think
structurally and abstractly what mass is
actually we were just asking as it
related to spin the answer is we were
just talking about that even on a live
stream yesterday about kind of what the
origin of particle spin is so if you're
interested in that I you might you might
want to check out the recording of that
um okay let's see I think we had a
question back here which I'll try to
address about yeah this
this question that caused me to go into
this long speech about intelligence and
measurement of intelligence and so on
had to do with animals and animal
intelligence and so on you know one of
the things people find fun that sort of
a science fiction thing is you know will
we be able to communicate with
extraterrestrials I think that question
is ultimately a badly formed question
but let's even imagine that's a question
the first sort of test case for that is
how about all the animals on the earth
can we communicate with them you know if
we've got you know if you've got a cat
or a dog or something you probably have
some at least emotional level
communication with with with the animal
um and there used to be a for a while
there was a product that was a dog human
translator that would would sort of
listen to the listen to the box of
different kinds of dogs and it would
kind of say translate that into one of
you know I don't know five or ten
phrases but really those related to more
or less emotional states for the dog and
that's some so that's sort of one level
of of communication but but so one
question would be what um how would one
you know if one was trying to sort of
figure out the intelligence of animals
you know well how about we have a
discussion with the animal we we ask it
things you know we see is it capable and
when we talk about intelligence of
computers and artificial intelligence a
pretty common thing as this thing called
the Turing test which is a question of
if if you had if you were typing in a
you know text messages to something okay
you type your text messages and you know
the question is do you know if it's a
human at the other end of the text
message stream or a bot in other words
by asking it questions you can say you
know you say things like what's your
favorite color or something let's say
some answer you say what's 2+2 it'll say
some answer the question is can you tell
by just sort of that channel of text
messaging can you tell whether the
at the other end is a human or a
computer and it's it's pretty hard that
there aren't really well it's there's
been very slow progress in making it
hard to tell
I mean people actually sometimes people
use our wolf alpha knowledge engine as
something to kind of give general
knowledge to a eyes that um can be used
for Turing test where you're trying to
figure out is it a human or a computer
at the other end and I've tried a few of
these things it's kind of funny because
you ask you a bunch of questions and you
know welcome alpha can answer those
questions but you know that no human
would be able to answer that set of
rather obscure questions so there you
nailed it it's a computer um but you
know this question about can we make an
AI that we can have a conversation with
and not be able to tell it isn't a human
it's an interesting thing we talked
about that separately but now you know
we're asking the question you know how
do we communicate so we're trying to
communicate with some animals some I
don't know a dolphin a something like
that what you know what's our medium of
communication
what um and you know for example for for
primates other than us there's you know
chimpanzees and things people have used
sign language they've used you know
things on an iPad where you're pointing
at different pictures of things and so
on to try and sort of form a channel of
communication and they're sort of
interesting questions about how far can
that get how sophisticated can the
language get and how sophisticated and
the concepts get one of the challenges
is you know as a famous philosopher
Ludwig Wittgenstein who was like if you
could talk to lions what would you talk
to them about in other words the life of
a lion is different from the life of a
person they have different kinds of
experiences they're different kinds of
things they care about what will be the
common themes that you could actually
talk about what would be the what would
be kind of the the the medium of
discussion you know would the language
would
would the lion be able to form
linguistic structures like we do you
know all human languages have nouns and
verbs and adjectives all of them now we
don't know whether that's because that's
how our brains are built whether that's
because they all sort of evolved in some
some correlated way it's not completely
clear we don't know whether that's
because of something to do with the way
that we think about the structure of
knowledge in the world I talk about this
at considerable length because I've
thought about it a lot but but you know
the question of for your average animal
would its language have the same
structure or not I'm kind of led to and
this question of sort of what's the
internal state of the animal does it
have a sort of a a model of the world
that's like ours does it figure things
out the way we figure things out about
the world hard to know it's you know
it's hard to know whether another person
figures things out the same way you
figure things out but the best you've
got in figured in in learning that is
talking to them and being able to ask
them questions and sort of being able to
sort of probe the shape of their kind of
of their way of thinking about things
you know I have to tell you excuse me um
many years ago I was involved in a very
silly project so actually many many
years ago I was for some reason was
trying to come up with silly inventions
that you might file patents for and
things like this and I had two silly
inventions at that time one of them was
an alarm clock that would decide when to
wake you up based on looking at your
brainwaves and the other was video games
for pets so
amusingly the the the brainwave alarm
clock thing it hasn't been it's not with
brainwaves but there are now alarm
clocks that you know sense your motion
and things when you're asleep to decide
what what cycle of sleep you're in and
whether that's a good one to wake you up
and so so that pseudo invention
eventually happened but the other one
video games for pets maybe five or six
years ago we were working with some
company that was interested in kind of
innovation and so on and I I was
actually all frustrated and I I
eventually said look you know let me
feed you
and innovation videogames for pets so
there was a branding company so they
were very very interested in that and so
we started seriously looking at um how
would you make really good video games
for pets and actually I had a I guess
was was longer ago than that because it
was right around the time the iPad came
out so was early 2010 or so um and the
so one of my challenges was could you
invent a game for the iPad that a cat
could win against its owner so you know
cats are quick you know cats are you
know have various characteristics humans
have various characteristics - can you
make a game on an iPad that a cat can
win against its owner so we got an
animal behavior expert involved in this
and started looking at it he said
problem is cats aren't gonna be
interested I said what about dogs
problem is dogs aren't going to be
interested there they're um you know
that they're more um no the problem is
dogs don't have good enough eyesight and
things and they you know they're more
smell related and so on and so it's not
gonna work with dogs but he was really
pushing the idea of cockatoos which are
social Birds and which are often kept
one at a time and so what this really
turned into was essentially a Twitter
for cockatoos project of a you know make
the social network for the cockatoos and
um you know there were always questions
like what we discovered that the that
cause of a cat couldn't scratch the
screen of an iPad and I think the beak
of a cockatoo could activate the screen
and so on unfortunately there's no
project never happened somebody should
really do this project um but one of the
things that I was particularly
interested in with that project is if
you give let's say cockatoos a means of
constructing things you know a a
Minecraft for cockatoos or something
what would they construct and would they
construct something that you know might
look completely random to us but it
might be deeply meaningful to themselves
or another cockatoo for that matter and
you know what would what would the
animal build
you gave the animal a means to build
things and unfortunately never did that
project I I'm hoping somebody will
eventually do that and we'll be able to
see what is the what is the great
literature of you know of the lions or
the cockatoos or whatever else because
we don't know now we may be in a
situation where we look at it and it's
like this was just a bunch of random
bits you know this was is this really a
Minecraft you know what did they make
its just something totally random we as
humans just don't understand the
significance of it at all
we might be in that situation I think
another thing that I've also been
waiting for is you know when do we get
to talk to the animals you know when I
was a kid there with these dr. Doolittle
books about this veterinarian who talked
to animals that were kind of cool and
it's a question is okay why can't we
talk to animals
well one question is do we actually have
a common set of things to talk to them
about but imagine we could make sort of
the Universal Translator where we say
you know tell me what kind of what your
favorite kind of cat food is or more
tell me why you like a red ball of wool
more than you like a black ball of wool
okay and let's say we could communicate
that and it would turn into a you know
meow purr whatever thing for a cat or
whatever it is um and and then the cat
would respond with uh you know whatever
the cat responds with or maybe the cat
would respond with some gesture with
it's poor or something or maybe the cat
would respond on an iPad by you know
moving things around the question is can
we you know what can we detect about you
know could we could we learn that
language you know it's like like we've
tried to learn you know people will go
into you know the the middle of the
Amazon jungle where there may be still
some tribes that haven't had contact
with the outside world and you know it's
like can you learn the language of this
tribe well you know it's kind of like
well you learn it because they pointer
you know they're these things actually
as a as a when you when you do
linguistics there are maybe 7,000
languages that are still extant around
the world maybe maybe 10,000 and there's
there's often there's things
Swadesh lists which are kind of lists of
very basic words like person fish you
know this tree this kind of thing that
are a limited set of words that one
knows and lots of languages and where
imagine you were sort of plopped down
and you're sort of trying to find a way
to communicate you can point it the
thing and it's like you say tree that's
a tree okay so you know how do you how
do you make the same kind of you know
you you you can do this with with humans
people have done this many times of sort
of learning being plopped down in some
place and learning the local language so
to speak you know could we learn the
local language of the animals you know I
I have to say I've sort of thought that
with modern machine learning and so on
it might be possible and you know you
basically sort of record the environment
of the animal you record how it responds
different kinds of things and you you
kind of then detect what is it's sort of
vocalization of things based on what
it's seen I mean I think one of the
cases of this is whale songs you know
whales have these long elaborate sort of
sounds that they make that get
transmitted through the deep ocean and
in the deep ocean sort of it's a
paradoxical thing but sound travels a
long way and deep ocean so you can have
one whale as kind of having a
conversation with a whale a thousand
miles away or is it having a
conversation we don't know for sure we
don't know whether you know the kind of
whale songs that are made are actually
transmitting information you know being
you know maybe they're telling the the
epic of the I was going to say the the I
I wouldn't be a good thing to say the
epic of Moby Dick or something you know
maybe they're saying some you know maybe
they're reciting a whale epic to some
other whale that's then going to reira
cite that whale epic to other whales and
that that's been going on you know
across you know halfway across the
Pacific Ocean for a long time we don't
know that might well have been happening
just like songbirds are continually
making songs which other birds respond
to you know are those songs meaningful
and conveying information in this way
that we think about information or are
they just purely you know like like I
will admit that I
sometimes whistle when I work and I'm
quite sure that my whistling conveys no
useful information and is quite horribly
tuneless - and you know maybe that's
what the birds are doing they're just
hanging out whistling as they as they
hang out so to speak or maybe that's
sort of actually meaningful information
how do you tell you know how do you tell
like come you know and maybe the way you
tell is you try and correlate something
that happened to one bird or some
environment that one bird is in you try
and say is that environment affecting
the the bird song is it affecting the
whales song can we determine that effect
can we maybe use machine learning to
learn the effect of something and how
that is vocalized by that by that
critter and if we could do that maybe we
could learn something where where we
could be able to either decode what the
creature saw or is talking about or even
be able to tell it like another one of
its species would tell it something so
it's kind of a you know could we imagine
making sort of the universal translator
for for creatures I think it's an
interesting question and I don't think
it's hopeless and it's again it's
actually in the in the spectrum of
things people have tried to do or not
tried to do I don't think anybody's
tried to do that for a very very long
time if ever and probably not with
modern techniques and so on it might not
be that hard or it might be might be the
other possibilities you might find out
that it's essentially impossible because
those critters kind of world views and
models of the world are just so
completely different from ours that
meaningful sort of serious communication
isn't actually possible okay we should
wrap up soon here but let me just look
at um um okay JJ is asking what
all that I play in my own kids education
some of my kids don't like me talking
about them but I'll tell you a little
bit okay so I have four kids the oldest
is well they range from their early 20s
down to the mid teens I'm so my my my
top three oldest three children did a
whole bunch of home schooling and that
mostly consisted of particularly for my
oldest son of kind of he decided stuff
he wanted to learn about and then he
would he actually got into doing kind of
the whole cycle of you know right ad and
Craigslist for teacher about such and
such read resumes you know talk to
teachers pick one
you know then learn about some subject
so he had the sort of good fortune I
suppose to to just learn about stuff he
wanted to learn about and I was like I
wondered whether it would sort of
gradually fill in and he would learn
about so everything that was that was
sort of in the point out to him look his
the encyclopedia you know let's pick a
random volume you know is there
something interesting in this volume and
actually the interesting thing was he
recently was that oh that's kind of
interesting oh that's kind of
interesting about sort of everything in
all these different volumes and so
that's um and my gosh I would say my
older daughter is a math graduate
student student so I suppose that's a
that's a math II thing although she used
to say that her her her act of teenage
rebellion was to know nothing about
computers um although I later learnt
that she knew a lot more than she she'd
let on and part of the explanation she
was did online high school and she was
keen to travel and so would um I hadn't
been traveling for a long time and she
sort of said you get all these
invitations to all over the world
let me pick the ones that are worth
going to and and then she'll come along
and so she did that and her eventual
explanation for how she knows more than
one would think she would know is do you
know how many incredibly boring lectures
that you've given in weird countries
around the world
I've been sitting at the back at doing
something else you know I did absorb a
certain amount of stuff there and then I
have a son who has a little bit more
public profile Christopher who has is a
very capable computational person who I
reckon is about twice as fast at
programming and more from language as I
am right now and kind of uses it sort of
it he's an interesting you can go look
at his website I think it's just
Christopher Wolfram calm and he just
does projects with computation all the
time and you know the thing that is
interesting to see is I know right now
he's doing something about Babylonian
history actually um and was doing some
other stuff to do with the pandemic and
modeling that but for him it's just like
he knows this computational stuff well
enough that he can just you know open up
a notebook and he is typing code and
doing things and doing things that are
like well nobody in these fields was
able to do that before because they
didn't have that fluency with
computational tools so um he's some an
example where I was sort of interesting
in his case I think um I think I'm
allowed to tell this story um where you
know he became a very capable
computational person long before he
would learn math and things like that
and he he would say for a long time I'm
not gonna learn this math stuff now why
do I need to know how to do all this
math stuff look I could just type it
into a computer and we'll do it and then
I remember when he was quite young I
remember remember it was like I'm trying
to persuade him to to learn how to do
multiplication
maybe an edition of love not long
numbers and things he's like why do I
need to know how to do this you know I
just type it into the computer it'll do
it eventually I was saying to him you
know well aren't you at least curious
how the computer does it so yes he was
curious about that he says but I bet
it's not going to do it the same way I'm
gonna do it as a person and so then you
know I suppose this is a specific to me
kind of thing what he was like let's go
look at the source code of you know
let's go look at the code zero it
actually works and of course it's
incredibly complicated and it doesn't do
it and anything like the way that that
humans do it and so it was like well
look I'm you know that's very
unconvincing you know but look I think I
think I'm yeah anyway so Christopher was
for a while a a pure play example of a
kid who knew computation well but didn't
know things like math and you know there
was a particularly amusing case where he
invented an algorithm which actually is
used in Wolfram language now for doing
nearest neighbor finding which is a
pretty mathy algorithm and you know so
it was like he was explaining this thing
to people and people would say oh that's
interesting use of this math thing that
thing he's like that's not math that's
just obvious and you know and in the end
sort of you know he had learnt
computation but had looked not learnt
traditional math and you know he could
sort of write down the differential
equations for some physical system but
hadn't the slightest idea how to solve
even the simplest differential equation
himself as a human and that was but
unfortunately he's no longer so
pure-play because he did learn sort of
human human based math which is sort of
sort of spoils the effect but you know
look I would say another thing about my
kids is that um one thing that's
probably matter useful
perhaps is that perhaps one of the more
educational things they've seen is you
know they know about projects I've done
and they'll know about you know they'll
hear about these projects I'm doing and
they'll you know know about them
I'll have opinions about them etc
etcetera etcetera and often it'll go
from a project where they're saying well
like the physics projects a good example
my kids were very unconvinced about that
project for for quite a while and and
then ah you know it's sort of
interesting for for anyone and one's
kids in particular to see these things
that go from it's just an idea - oh it's
a real thing that actually exists in the
world and so on and I think that that
going you know being able to see that
one could have an idea and it would turn
into something real is a really
important sort of thing to know and I
know well I suppose I mean I I don't
know what's the nature-nurture etc
etcetera etcetera but all of my kids are
very much in the I'll have an idea and
I'll turn it into something real um so
it's some in very different domains but
but um the I think that's it I mean one
of the things that I find I find sort of
really odd sometimes with kids is that
you say oh what are your parents do I
say oh I don't know they're kind of like
my um youngest child was just relating
some story about some somebody that time
I said person was saying oh they're
their dad is a CEO so my my kid had
asked him you know what is the company
that the CEO what does it do and it was
like well I don't really know okay but
the the thing is you know knowing what
one's parents do is it's a great data
point it's like you know your parents
probably fairly well and you can see
what they do and you can
see what works what doesn't work you
know how maybe the mistakes they make
the things you think a totally goofy the
the things that look kind of interesting
etc etc etc and it's it's it's really
good data of course you might ask you
might be asking what did my parents do
and okay so the so my father was ran a
business which in its day was well he
started it kind of got into it um right
after World War two and it was an
import-export business in England
dealing with textiles well at that time
being an import-export business dealing
with textiles was kind of like a
high-tech leading-edge kind of thing
roll the clock forward 50 years and it's
not quite so high tech or what kite so
leading-edge and so I would always be
quite dismissive of the kind of um you
know oh it's it's kind of an old old old
boring kind of business but that he he
ran it for about 50 years actually um
and and then on the side he wrote novels
and which I am embarrassed to say I
didn't read until quite recently and
it's one of my poor poor child behavior
type type of poor child performance some
things is that but I you know to be fair
I'm not sure that my kids have written
read books that I've written so so maybe
that's just the way of the way of the
world um but there my mother I was a
philosophy professor in Oxford and she
um I actually have read at least one
book she wrote about philosophical logic
and you know one of the things about
having a philosophy professor as a
parent is well one of the things I
always used to say when I was a kid is
if there's one thing I'll never do when
I'm grown up its do philosophy and yet
I've ended up doing a lot of things that
sort of amount to philosophy I think one
story I
kind of like to tell I remember I was at
some some party that I was sort of I
think that was the you know the child
childminding of the five or six year old
me was bring them along to some some
random philosopher party or something
and I was some you know of course the
only kid there and there was some white
haired old philosopher who came over to
me and started this long conversation
with me and you know I have to say it
reminds me because I've been at parties
where I'm like these adults they're
there so so but there's some kid over in
the corner let me go talk to the kid
because that'll be more interesting um
and I suspect that's what kind of
happened in this case but anyway I have
this long conversation with this chap
and afterwards it's um you know he's
walking away and he's kind of mumbling
and he's saying one day that child will
be a philosopher but it may take a while
and you know yes it probably took him
many many decades after that time before
I I got involved in those kinds of
things but I thought that was kind of
amusing I mean I think that the the
thing that Tim it's some I anyway that's
so that's and yes I did know what my
parents did and I would sort of I would
hear the philosophy I think my mother
actually used to try out sort of when I
was you know six seven years old and
things would try out these questions
that were for philosophy under graduates
would try them out on me although that
wasn't I didn't know that was what was
going on but I think that was so that
was some if I'd known that I probably
would have been more amused by the whole
thing then it's like me just saying it's
obvious that whatever whatever whatever
whatever whatever um and um because I
would always be like look it's obvious
you can just work this out and this and
listen this way I didn't really realize
until long afterwards that probably
those things which I was saying it's
obvious that whatever not everybody
might have
you know untangled them in those ways
and so on and I think that Tim yeah I
mean you know if you're curious in the
the thing that Tim yeah I mean you know
people are saying wish their parents had
told them more about their jobs just ask
just show interest your parents will
appreciate it well speaking as a parent
of you know when my kids decide that
something I'm doing is actually
interesting it's like that's really cool
and of course they often have they often
have opinions about you know that's a
waste of time that's a good idea
whatever
that quite often right actually um the I
think um you know it's a for some reason
people I think people get into the point
of view where it's like well I've been a
kid for 15 years and you know I didn't
find out about what my parents do why
I'm asking them today well find an
excuse because just because when you
were five years old it didn't make sense
to find out what your you know parent
who's a you know financial engineer does
or something like this it doesn't mean
that it doesn't make sense you know when
you're 15 years old
and you might actually find that your
parents know things that are sort of
worth knowing so to speak
and I think that Tim I mean I think one
of the things with with my kids is they
know a lot of stuff that I think is
interesting and so I'm always asking
them things about stuff that they know
about an occasionally they'll ask me
things about stuff I know about and I
think it's kind of the the very fact
that I'm asking them about things that
they know about is probably why you know
otherwise they'd never think to ask me
about what I know about probably um and
I also look I think that um you know one
thing probably with my kids is it's like
I'm probably about as like just um go
try and do that sure why not
maybe people would say it's you know
it's it's it's crazy but sure why don't
you try and do it it's some and usually
it works out and that my my oldest son
who got into business very very young
did that a bunch with him and it worked
out really well and actually you'll
probably find if you go look on the web
my son Christopher I don't think he's
completely disowned this when he was
probably oh I don't know what eleven
maybe the we were going to I was going
to make a fair event and I was supposed
to be giving some talk there and he says
what are you gonna talk about I tell him
he says that's totally boring you know
people are just gonna fall asleep that's
just a total lose so it was like okay
well maybe you should give the talk
instead so he said well maybe maybe and
then so eventually he was like sure you
know I'll do it and he was it was a time
when the first drones first quadruped
two drones and things were available and
he decided he would do something because
it was a maker type event do something
where it's like programming a you know
doing real-time programming of of one of
these drones and so I'm like okay you
know do make sure you've tested it you
know anything that can go wrong with an
audience will go wrong and so it's like
I don't know for 500 people there or
something and so he's like it tries it
out and of course something goes wrong
and so he's doing kind of real-time
debugging and and there there are videos
of this and watch one but but um and it
was it was I was the thing I was most
impressed by was how how calm he managed
to be just like okay I'm gonna do bug
this you know etc etc etc and I I
thought it was I thought it was gonna be
hopeless and wasn't gonna work and it
was it was all but eventually it worked
drone took off flew around and I was
quite quite a quite a cool event um and
you know exactly where the the
look I admit that the doing real-time
demos in front of audiences which is
something I've done for a long time is
one of those Apple of the next
generation doesn't fall far away from
the tree type of thing although maybe
it's also because like he'd see me do
that a bunch instead he figured look if
the if that if that slow old old fogey
can do it then the bright young ones
should be able to do it too
um okay let's see I think we should
probably um try to wrap up there um well
it's some sorry you got me off talking
on about some all sorts of weird topics
fun for me I've this is some I can see
that during the time I was talking to
you guy you guys hundreds of emails came
in many of them about my day job many of
them also about physics project so I've
got I've got my work cut out here there
anyway it's it's been fun to talk to you
guys and look forward to doing this
again and thanks for being here and good
bye have good weekends